à ce ailleurs qui vivent une toute autre
vie
je pense beaucoup à l'Ukraine je sais
pas ce que fait Thomas auto derrière moi
les 24 les 24 qui mènent
est-ce que vous voulez bien me dire que
vous déclarez ouvert la première saison
de c'est à vous à Cannes je déclare
ouverte la première saison de cette
avoir à Cannes en anglais ça me va très
bien merci
je crois que vous avez quelque chose à
nous dire ah oui c'est vrai
on croyait que l'essentiel avait été dit
mais non pardon evidemment
pardon je déclare ouvert le 76e Festival
de Cannes
on va commencer avec vous Carla comment
j'ai entendu quoi
[Musique]
je suis gay
voilà et en français c'est vrai qu'on a
pas mal de mots pour le dire il y a [__]
bien sûr qu'on peut écrire [__] ou PDA ça
c'est vraiment comme on veut il y a
tarlouz il y a [__] il y a tapiole
que j'aime bien moi mais bon ça fait un
moment que je l'ai pas entendu
bonjour
et puis bien sûr il y a [__] vous avez
été victime d'un viol vous le racontez
j'avais 13 ans lui 35 vous dites ça
piquer un peu et dans votre spectacle
vous dites on essaie on est assez sévère
avec le viol en général il n'y a pas que
des inconvénients
c'est hyper trash hyper dur à entendre
mais pourquoi vous avez décidé d'en rire
j'ai décidé d'en rire parce que déjà
c'était quelque chose je l'ai écrit
pendant le premier confinement le
spectacle et c'est un moment où on sait
tous confronté à nos solitudes nos
névroses etc j'ai senti ce truc qui
revenait un peu il y a des gynécologues
qui vous disent il y a beaucoup de
patients qui viennent régulièrement
parce qu'elles aiment ça
va pas non plus
je vous dis un témoignage précis de
Nono mais très très sérieux très précisé
par contre je connais des proctologues
qui a compris au bout d'un moment que le
monsieur venait souvent parce qu'il
aimait beaucoup le le toucher
dans rire de ce vieux il s'est passé ça
et c'est ça c'est ce pourquoi je trouve
ça drôle c'est parce que ça s'est passé
comme c'est comme ça qu'il avait 35 ans
que qu'il avait une coupe mulet enfin
que du coup j'ai pas de chance parce que
vraiment c'est encore pire quoi vous
avez vraiment très très loin alors
qu'est-ce que fait le comité d'éthique
avec les gens qui viennent se faire des
toucher recto parce que ça leur fait
plaisir est-ce qu'on dit c'est le
problème
difficile de la sécurité sociale est-ce
que vous acceptez de me faire un truc
avec ça
non pas aujourd'hui je reviendrai plus
alors c'est comme ça je voudrais
à l'époque au début des années 80
l'arrivée brutale d'une nouvelle maladie
va profondément aggraver ces
discriminations envers les homosexuels
le sida qualifié de cancer gay fera 40
000 morts en France
je suis la génération du sida je suis je
m'en suis tiré j'en suis tout j'en suis
toujours étonné d'ailleurs de m'en être
absolument tiré et donc parmi mes amis
ça a été un carnage j'avais l'impression
de perdre un ami tous les trois mois ça
a été vraiment très très dur et moi
l'hypnose c'est ma j'en suis fan Julien
ça fait 37 ans que j'ai endormi ma femme
et ça se passe c'est vrai merci Bernard
qui est vraiment
pourquoi là vous voyez pardon
sérieux tout ce qui trouve à dire c'est
non mais c'est vrai ça a bien marché
et désolé je sais que je roule très très
très très très vite après bon j'ai
l'excuse mais je sais qu'elle est pas
valable je vérifie si je suis cocu ce
soir ce nouveau virus apparaît pour
beaucoup comme la preuve scientifique
que l'homosexualité est un danger
[Musique]
alors ça transpiration
de l'épreuve et celui-là je souhaiterais
qu'il soit dans un centre avec un
personnel spécialisé avec des règles
d'hygiène strictes
il ne peut pas changer de chaîne
le gland c'est lui qui se passe dans le
public là
qu'est-ce qui se passe là
et non
le micro s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
merci vite là si je vois des gens là qui
s'agitent dans le public là qu'est-ce
qui se passe là
et deux heures là qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est quoi l'embrouille en parlant de
bienveillance qui chantait déjeuner en
paix P a I x parce que notamment c'est
un peu
c'est pas possible là c'est le moment où
il faut saluer une autre championne une
championne de la répartie qui a fait un
des plus beaux coming out télévisés
Catherine Lara
qu'est-ce que vous regardez en premier
chez un homme
[Rires]
bonsoir pardon en fait je suis désolé je
vous prie de m'excuser Madame mes 7
personnes n'arrête pas de parler je
pense qu'elle voudrait peut-être sortir
elle ne supporte plus l'émission
et oui mais vous dérangez vous dérangez
des spectateurs et des spectacles je
suis désolée ça devient vraiment pénible
donc les chéris s'il vous plaît merci un
peu de calme merci
[Musique]
une attaque de requin-tigre au large de
l'île d'ohout dans l'archipel d'Hawaï
j'ai entendu un bruit comme un bateau
sans moteur qui s'approchait de moi et
j'ai levé les yeux et j'ai vu cette
énorme chose mon cerveau a d'abord pensé
que c'était une tortue mais ensuite ça
m'a frappé et j'ai réalisé que c'était
un requin tigre
oui
les gars
je te remercie Patrick
merci Alain Bourgoin du bourre dans un
instant c'est à vous est avec vous pour
vous accompagner jusqu'à 20h55 il me
reste 3 secondes pour emmerder Patrick 1
2 3
j'ai pas le temps on est coupé